bonjour alors comme on vient de me
présenter je m'appelle emilie capri j'ai
36 ans je suis marié et je suis maman de
deux petits garçons de 12 et 4 ans et
vous allez voir que tout ce qui me
décris ne sont que des clichés
allez c'est parti jusqu'à preuve du
contraire je suis une femme et je vous
assure qu être une femme dans la vie de
tous les jours c'est un vrai combat il
faut arrêter de penser que la femme
c'est légal de l'homme se serait
utopique et moi dans le métier dans
lequel je travaille je me bats tous les
jours
deuxième cliché je suis blonde et oui
tout le monde connaît les blagues sur
les blondes
on a juste à taper sur internet pour
voir à peu près ce que ça peut donner
on s'en fait une petite pour détendre un
peu l'atmosphère à votre avis combien de
blondie faut pour changer une ampoule
pas aucune puisque toute façon le temps
qu'elle comprenne il fera déjà jours
voilà c'est à peu près l'image que la
société a des blancs d'aujourd'hui
troisième cliché
j'ai mis des talons important mais je
suis pas très grande c'est vrai que le
dernier concert d'eros ramazzotti à
l'aréna dans l'art dans la fosse j'ai eu
le sont mais j'ai pas eu beaucoup
l'image
et puis ensuite je suis jeune oui désolé
36 ans pour vous ça peut peut-être
paraître déjà l'âge des dinosaures mais
moi dans le monde dans lequel je
travaille je ne suis qu'une gamine qui
doit faire ses preuves tous les jours et
enfin le pire de tous les clichés
je suis la femme du patron vous imaginez
celle que personne m
qui dit bonjour à personne quand elle
arrive dans la société qui a tous les
passe droits enfin je vous rassure je
suis pas comme ça parce que je pense que
si vraiment je l'était je serais pas
devant vous aujourd'hui
alors on résume je suis une femme blonde
petites jeunes et femmes de patron à
votre avis avec un profil comme ça
qu'est ce que je fais dans la vie
et bien je suis vendeuse de cailloux et
oui alors pas les cailloux que vous
imaginez les diamants ou les rubis qui
coûte très cher et qui brille non non
pas du tout moi c'est plutôt comme
obélix les gros bien encombrant et bien
lourds destinés à la construction et à
l'aménagement des maisons
voilà c'est plutôt ça
et cette société de cailloux je la
dirige avec mon mari
donc en gros je suis la patronne et vous
allez voir comment au final tous ces
clichés qui aurait peut-être pu me
décourager on fait en sorte que j'ai pu
faire carrière dans la pierre naturelle
mais au fait comment j'ai atterri dans
la pierre naturelle parce que au début
la pierre naturelle
je connaissais rien du tout la
construction je ne connaissais pas non
plus mais c'est grâce à mon mari quand
on est sortis de l'université de savoie
on s'est dit pourquoi on commencerait
pas à travailler pour nous vu l'énergie
qu'on met dans les entreprises des
autres alors nous voilà partis dans le
vide tous les deux à reprendre la
société familiale de ses parents qui
étaient vendeurs de pierre naturelle
mais il a quand même fallu apprendre
parce que moi une étanchéité du bea 13
un placo c'était du chinois
alors à votre avis comment j'ai fait
pour apprendre
eh ben j'ai fait ma blonde j'ai pas trop
parler j'ai beaucoup écouté j'ai pris
des notes
j'ai assimilé j'ai imité et je me suis
beaucoup hein
mes beaux parents en fait mon beaucoup
transmis ce qui fait que petit à petit
j'ai réussi à faire ma place au niveau
technique mais au final c'était pas tant
l'apprentissage qui allait être un
problème c'était de se faire accepter
dans un monde de la construction
dans un monde où les maçons les
carreleurs ça fait 30 ans qu'ils
travaillent de la même manière avec les
mêmes personnes alors je vous avoue que
la question arriver assez vite quand le
maçon depuis 40 ans arrivé au showroom
il me disait il pas la vôtre beau père
ah ben non désolé mais c'est pas grave
vous savez je peux vous renseigner il
n'y a pas de problème non non écouter
laissé tomber je reviendrai demain lé
merci au revoir un et je vous assure que
c'est arrivé bien plus de fois que vous
pouvez l'imaginer
alors là eh ben il faut garder courage
il faut pas se décourager et avec ma
persévérance et mon contact facile et
les encouragements de ma famille
j'ai réussi petit à petit à faire ma
place dans ce monde là il y avait même
des maçons et des carreleurs qui arrive
à me demander pour m'occuper de leur
chantier imaginez ma fierté
mais ce à quoi j'avais pas forcément
pensé c'était les réunions de chantier
oui parce que vous savez quand on est
dans le monde de la construction
souvent à un moment donné il faut aller
à une réunion de chantier pour aborder
les aspects techniques alors je vous
plante le décor ben en fait vous
arrivait souvent les pieds dans la boue
dans la cabane de jardin il ya une
vingtaine de bonhomme d'à peu près le
gabarit d'une équipe de rugby qui vous
voit arriver et qui se dit mais qu'est
ce qu'elle fait là elle s'est perdue
elle c'est pas possible c'est je vous
assure que ça donne vraiment ça et la
première fois que je suis arrivée à une
réunion de chantier
j'ai vraiment eu très peur alors on
ferme petit rappel quand même hein faut
savoir que le secteur de la construction
c'est le secteur qui se féminise le
moins il ya seulement 2 % de femmes dans
la construction et sur la totalité des
dirigeants 97 % sont des hommes
donc ce qui signifie que je suis une
exception à moi tout seul
revenons sur notre réunion de chantier
alors madame vous êtes qui la cliente
non bon bah vous devez être l'architecte
non plus non non je suis la vendeuse de
cailloux alors l'incidence oui je vous
assure silence parce que ces règles sur
une réunion de chantier c'est plutôt des
engueulades parce qu'on est en retard
c'est plutôt décrit enfin voila c'est
souvent le joyeux bordel mais le silence
il reste pas très longtemps puisque les
clichés faut pas les oublier
un homme dans la construction pour se
faire entendre
il doit crier c'est comme ça moi en tant
que femme
si je faisais la même chose on prendrait
pour une hystérique alors eh bien il
faut trouver d'autres moyens
parce que quand vous êtes face aux
maçons d'un mètre 95 et que vous devez
lui dire vie donc tu voudrais pas te
ment c'est un petit peu pour que je
puisse commencer à livrer mes pierre bon
ben vous essayez de faire les choses
différemment de lui dire gentiment ou
alors carrément de lui dire écoute tu
sais quoi si t'es pas content tu parce
que oui le tutoiement dans la
construction il faut plutôt passer par
sa si vous voulez vous faire accepter
donc si t'es pas content ya pas de
problème on va voir le client et on va
lui expliquer que tu es en retard
bon alors là finalement ça s'arrange en
général donc une femme c'est vrai que
peut-être que sur un chantier elle
arrivera à faire passer plus de choses
qu'un homme on voit les choses
différemment mais malheureusement parler
dire les choses ça solutionne pas tout
et ya de temps en temps des moments de
crise qui sont assez difficiles à gérer
humainement et je vais vous en raconter
un c'est une petite anecdote qui m'est
arrivé sur un chantier il n'y a pas très
longtemps on est de livrer à peu près
six ou sept salles de bain dans une
villa de luxe
donc on avait livré tous les marbres des
salles de bains et le client me demande
de venir sur le chantier alors moi
j'arrive assez sereine puisque tout
s'était bien passé jusqu'à maintenant et
en fait juste en croisant le regard du
client
j'ai compris que la réunion allait pas
se passer aussi sereinement que j'allais
l'imaginé donc il arrive et là me prend
assez violemment par le bras il m'emmène
dans la première salle de bains ont déjà
je me dis la manière de faire bon bref
on va voir il arrive dans la salle de
bain et il me dit mais qu'est ce que
c'est que ça c'est pas du tout ce que
j'ai choisi
alors heureusement j'arrive à lui montré
avec mon ipad et les photos mais si
c'est bien étrange que vous avez choisi
oui mais c'est pas la bonne finition si
si je vous assure garder sur les plans
on avait bien noté cette finition c'est
tout bon alors là vous vous dites
montmagny qu'elle à solutionner son
problème elle vient de lui montrer
qu'elle avait raison sauf que ce que
j'ai oublié de vous dire c'est que le
client
ils étaient mexicains et qu'une petite
femme blonde qui venait de lui tenir
tête et de lui montrer qu'il avait tort
c'était pas la bonne solution donc là il
rattrape par le bras et il me fait
descendre les escaliers jusqu'au sous
sol donc là je lui montre gentiment que
déjà ça me déplaît il fait en sorte de
me faire rentrer dans une salle de bain
et puis avec l'architecte qui font
barrière pour que mon commercial qui
m'avaient accompagné ne puisse pas
rentrer donc là je me retrouve dans une
salle de bain de 10 mètres carrés face à
un mexicain assez costaud et là le
client s'énerve violemment en me disant
c'est pas du tout ce que j'avais
commandé et maariv dessus et là je me
dis mais c'est pas possible je veux en
venir aux mains
donc le stress et l'énervement les
montrent les larmes commence à monter
mais je me dis surtout ne lui ment
repas reste forte jusqu'à maintenant on
parlait en français mais sachant que
l'anglais est sa langue maternelle je me
dis change de langues qui va peut-être
arriver à le calmer en parlant un
anglais
donc je commence à lui expliqué en
anglais que tous les marbres qu'on a
choisi il les a validés que j'ai les
mails que j'ai tous les écrits et
peut-être que en sortant de cette salle
de bain qui était en fait un guet-apens
je pourrais peut-être lui montrer sur
l'ordinateur toutes les preuves et là on
arrive finalement à sortir de la salle
de bain alors pour la petite anecdote y
avait quand même 5 bonhomme à la sortie
de la salle de bains qui attendaient
leur tour pour la réunion de chantier
mais y en a pas un qui a bougé entendant
ce qui se passait dans la salle de bain
par contre ils ont baissé les yeux quand
je suis passé donc là on a continué la
visite de chantier et puis au final
toutes les salles de bains allait plus
ou moins bien alors je lui dis mais
c'est quoi le problème vous voulez quoi
vous voulez qu'on casse tout et qu'on
recommence et là il me répond mais non
pas du tout
c'était juste pour vous donner mon âme
et mon mécontentement d'accord très bien
on termine la visite on arrive à la fin
et là le client vient de prendre les
mains très chaleureusement m dit merci
beaucoup madame cap read est devenu
vraiment j'ai apprécié cette réunion
alors là vous imaginez que j'ai bien
vite enlevé mes mains et que je lui ai
simplement répondu écoutez c'est normal
c'était mon travail est là je suis parti
je monte dans la voiture avec mon
commercial les larmes étaient toujours
au bord 1 mais elle sortait pas et en
fait ce qui m'a rendu le plus dingue
c'est pas la manière dont il m'a parlé
ce qui m'a rendu le plus dingue c'est
que si ça avait été mon mari en face de
lui il se serait jamais permis de me
parler et de faire ce qu'il avait fait
ce jour là
alors oui être une femme dans mon monde
de tous les jours c'est un vrai combat
alors finalement pas toutes ses
difficultés
ça pousse à se demander qu'est ce qu'on
peut apporter et grâce à ma formation à
l'université de savoie on en fait un
petit peu la pub quand même spécialité
marketing
quand je suis arrivé dans l'entreprise
familiale le marketing comment vous dire
dans la société caprice était du bouche
à oreille alors somme toute c'est la
meilleure des communications
et puis
une petite foire locale qui nous a fait
connaître pendant 20 ans mais un soir je
dis à mon mari mais comment je pourrais
expliquer à tes parents qu'il faudrait
qu'on investisse un petit peu plus dans
le marketing pour qu'on se fasse
connaître et qu'on se développe un peu
alors intibaha écoute pas de problème tu
fais une réunion demain matin et puis tu
leur expliques le marketing est ce que
tu as envie de faire ça paraît simple
comme ça ça vous vous retrouvez quand
même face à votre mari à vos
beaux-parents
et puis il faut quand même pas les
froisser pour pas qu'ils aient
l'impression que vous pensiez que ce
qu'ils ont fait jusqu'à maintenant était
mal alors que c'était tout le contraire
et puis je voulais pas qu'ils pensent
que je voulais tout révolutionner mais
bon je prépare ma petite réunion
montpetit powerpoint mes petites fiches
le lendemain matin on arrive dans le
bureau 10 mètres carrés les quatre
autour de la table et là j'explique le
marketing les 4p les avantages des
conséquences bref et à la fin de la
réunion
ben mes beaux parents me disent tout
simplement memmie écoute on te fait
confiance avec bruno donc vous avez
carte blanche
maintenant à vous de nous montrer ce que
vous pouvez faire alors là la mission
marketing et est en route et donc on a
commencé à faire des parutions dans les
magazines on a commencé à revoir nos
sites internet à faire de la pub à la
radio qu'on ne pensait pas possible à
l'époque à faire des événements
commerciaux en faisant venir nos clients
directement au showroom et puis on a
même fait des soirées de fou mais des
soirées de fous où on a fait venir des
artistes du cirque du soleil avec 400
personnes des cracheurs de feu et en
fait c'est des choses que mes beaux
parents auraient peut-être jamais
imaginé possible dans le monde dans
lequel on évolue parce que n'oubliez pas
qu'on évolue dans le monde de la
construction
mais qu'on avait on a eu des super
retombées commerciales
suite à ce genre de choses alors
heureusement en tant que femme
il ya aussi des choses qui sont plus
simples et puis une fois que vous avez
fait votre place une fois que vous avez
déjà apporté certaines choses et bien
être une femme dans le monde de la
décoration
ça peut être un avantage parce qu'en
fait il faut pas oublier que dans un
projet de construction à 97%
c'est la femme dans le couple qui aura
le dernier mot et oui désolé messieurs
mais ça marche comme ça
et je peux vous assurer que tous les
jours je vois ça au showroom et alors ça
tombe bien puisque je suis une femme
aussi donc on parle à peu près le même
langage instagram pinto reste les
nuances de couleurs les finitions enfin
tout ce à quoi le mari répondre aime et
fais comme tu veux chéri donc on
s'éclate au showroom entre femmes avec
les architectes avec les décoratrices
avec les clients de finale et c'est vrai
que tous les matins je me lève pas ce
que parce que ça me plaît et parce qu'en
fait je suis devenu une vraie passionnée
de la pierre naturelle et je pense qu'à
un moment donné quand vous êtes
passionné si vous arrivez à transmettre
cette passion à vos clients
mais je pense que c'est gagné alors je
crois que j'ai fait carrière dans la
pierre naturelle et au final mon
parcours ils relèvent davantage du
parcours de la combattante que celui de
la voie royale
je gagne ces petits combats jour après
jour pour devenir manager ceux qui comme
vous l'imaginez et déjà de tout repos au
départ c'est vrai que ce métier moi la
pierre naturelle
j'étais pas forcément passionné et je me
demande encore des fois qu'est ce qui
m'a poussé finalement à relever tous ces
défis
à votre avis est-ce qu'on n'a pas tous
eu un jour envie de monter sur le
tabouret pour aller attraper le pot de
confiture auquel justement nous avait
interdit
est ce que finalement être là où on ne
vous attend pas renverser les barrières
que les gens mettent en travers de votre
chemin
est-ce que c'est pas ça la plus
puissante des motivations est-ce que la
difficulté c'est pas ça qui vous
poussent à découvrir et à développer vos
passions tenez vous chacun d'entre vous
je suis sûr qu'il ya quelque chose qui
vous passionne et dont vous ne pensez
pas pouvoir faire un jour votre métier
mais au final qui vous en empêche si ce
n'est vous même alors voila merci de
m'avoir écouté et j'espère que ces
quelques mots vous aideront à dépasser
vos craintes et les clichés qu'on peut
tous avoir un jour d'en rencontrer dans
sa vie et on va juste laisser la place à
la musique pour terminer parce que les
paroles de cette musique
elle me parle assez parce qu'au final
j'aurais peut-être aussi peut être une
punk rockeuse
attention
pied
hors japon quoi comme fly
merci